at six years old I was taking dance
classes late actor Cameron Boyce opens
up about being a child star in an
interview released one year after his
death I was the only kid who seemed
interested at all HBO has released the
trailer for showbiz kids a documentary
about child actors in Hollywood and
Cameron makes an appearance that changed
the entire fabric of my family and the
way that we work as a unit the doc drops
on July 14th just over a year after
Cameron died suddenly in his sleep at
the age of 20 after suffering a fatal
seizure amid his ongoing struggle with
epilepsy it was more so feeling that cam
gave when he was around you and I think
his sister put it so beautifully but he
was sunshine wearing shoes and that's
exactly who he is last month
ét caught up with Cameron's Descendants
co-star sophia carson who were called
the day she heard the tragic news I'll
never forget that day and I remember all
of us were just overwhelmed into
thinking that he was just the happiest
most beautiful soul and that no matter
what his soul will live on forever in
his legacy because he's loved by so many
and had the most selfless heart on
Monday sophia honored her late friend on
the anniversary of his death posting
this home video montage to Instagram
[Music]
in the caption she wrote quote not
having you hurts too much but somehow
you still managed to light up our whole
entire world its heart and his legacy is
living on in the Cameron voice
foundation wielding piece that his
family is so courageously and so
beautifully pouring their hearts into so
I urge anyone who's watching and anyone
who loved cam like we all day to
continue their legacy not only by
supporting the foundation but by being
late cam and that's just being someone
who loves first and foremost and doesn't
judge and just is like kindness walking
Cameron's dad Victor Boyce shared this
throwback pic writing his memory is a
blessing and another fellow descendants
co-star dove Cameron also took to social
media to share her cherished memories
posting a trio of snapshots to Instagram
and writing quote I will love you
forever just like this